[Music]
foreign
consider race in its admissions
processes moving forward that's at the
heart of one of the many remaining
Supreme Court decisions yet to be
announced this term students for fair
admissions is challenging the admission
processes at Harvard University and
within the University of North Carolina
system they allege Asians have been
excluded at Harvard and that Asians and
white people have suffered due to
affirmative action policies at UNC
during oral arguments last fall Justice
katanji Brown Jackson questioned an
attorney with students for fair
admissions the rule that you're
advocating that in the context of a
holistic review process the university
can take into account and value
all of the other background and personal
characteristics of other applicants but
they can't value race what I'm worried
about is that that seems to me to have
the potential of causing more of an
equal protection problem than it's
actually solving after hearing from
North Carolina solicitor general Ryan
Park on behalf of the University of
North Carolina Justice Clarence Thomas
said I've heard the word diversity quite
a few times and I don't have a clue what
it means
uh it seems to mean everything for
everyone to that and to Brown Jackson's
earlier Point Park said there are many
different diversity factors that are
considered as a greater factor in our
admissions process than race we have a
particular interest in recruiting and
enrolling rural North Carolinians the
universities insist race may be a factor
but it's just one and that they've
adhered to precedent here as the Supreme
Court has previously said such
consideration is allowed well the oral
arguments broke pretty much as most of
us expected you had a clear opposition
to the challenge coming from the left
side of the Court Jonathan Turley is a
constitutional law expert and professor
at George Washington University so
justices Sotomayor and Kagan and in one
case Justice Jackson really spoke
strongly against the basis of this
challenge Justice Jackson participated
only in one of the cases because she was
serving on the board for Harvard during
the relevant period of these actions the
oral argument was interesting to watch
particularly in the the interplay
between the lawyer for Harvard and the
court the Chief Justice Roberts kept on
needling Harvard and asking if Asian
Americans simply have no personality
because according to what the
challengers are arguing Harvard created
a test that included interviews and
essentially a personality ranking Asians
tended to be graded lower on that
criteria which made a difference in how
many of them were accepted at Harvard
and so chief justice Roberts kept on
asking what is it about Asian Americans
that you think are not really
competitive in terms of their
personality or their contributions and
it's at certain points Harvard sort of
floundered on that one the other thing
that was interesting is that they
generally General rate of admission
remained fairly constant during these
years and they also pressed on that how
if you're doing individual decision
making these percentages seem to be so
uniform so it was a very interesting
argument a lot of it came down to
statistics a lot of it came down to the
veracity of these universities as you
know a group of liberal arts college
professors signed a letter saying a
decision that would not allow the
consideration of race would make our
academic institutions less diverse and
quote would be tragic they write to
fulfill the promise of economic and
social Mobility we need to continue
rectifying these systemic barriers that
have kept so many talented students of
color out of higher education I wonder
as you listen to the oral arguments how
important was it to the case that
Harvard and UNC needed to make this idea
of systemic barriers that needed
assistance in overcoming well some of
the justices pushed back on those are
arguments particularly Justice Thomas
who did not believe that universities
should be in the business of selecting
people by their skin color or seeking to
maintain this diversity quotient as
opposed to maintaining high levels of
educational standards but there were
also more nuanced arguments many of us
have argued for years that the greatest
diversity that we see in our classrooms
the ones that are most relevant and
beneficial in classes tend to be
economic diversity where kids come from
it's it's not necessarily racial
diversity I have many African-American
and other students of color who come
from very affluent backgrounds the the
most interesting comments for me come
from the students from all Races who are
coming from impoverished backgrounds
rural backgrounds areas that are not
represented to the same degree at Nash
national law schools so this is part of
this ongoing debate but really one of
the things that really played
prominently in these debates is the fact
that the court has always struggled with
affirmative action we've had decades
since the bakkie decision in the 1970s
where the court just kept on Flipping
back and forth on whether race-based
programs were constitutional technically
Baki got rid of affirmative action in
higher education but universities as you
might imagine are very creative and they
find ways around that and what happened
is that the court allowed for
universities to consider race as part of
an overall context and what the
complaint has been is that universities
use that and maintained what is
effectively an affirmative action
program that Baki rejected
yeah the the really interesting moment I
think came when Justice is reminded
these schools that in cases like gruder
the court was very uncomfortable with
continuing the use of race as a criteria
and Justice O'Connor in one of these
prior cases said that she did not
believe that the court would continue to
allow race to be considered uh in 25
years or whatever period She mentioned
well that period is basically run uh
this the time is up and so a number of
these justices including chief justice
Roberts said look you keep on siding
that case this court according to
O'Connor gave you a period That's now
expired so why are you citing that case
we said back then that we wouldn't be
comfortable right now continuing that
type of criteria
yeah I read that that was a fascinating
part of the arguments that this idea
that there are sunsets right that things
expire at some point
um a Harvard law professor though to
your point about creativity told the
University newspaper that a university
like Harvard at a university like
Harvard you know not much would change
even if the Supreme Court ruled against
considering race and the College Board
in advising universities to prepare for
this ruling said you know make sure
you're applying a Dei lens A diversity
Equity inclusion lens throughout your
institution and message to your students
that your Dei policies still apply and
will remain untouched regardless of the
Supreme Court I wonder will much change
even if the court rules against
considering race
I don't think it will I've said this for
years that the universities have shown
great ability to circumvent these
rulings I think they'll do it again some
schools like the University of
California have moved against the
consideration of any objective scores
like the s.a.t because it interfered
with getting the greater diversity in
their classes well if you remove
standardized testing there is very
little ability to prove affirmative
action or race-based criteria because
you don't have as many objective uh data
points so what's fascinating is that
they've already started to put into
place a system that will make it
difficult for the next round of
challenges and I think what's going to
happen is that universities are going to
develop subtle ways of achieving the
same result people will write in their
essays about what it is like to be a
person of color so that school will be
aware of it you're going to have CDI
policies that actively you know select
students without necessarily mentioning
race and so those things are going to
likely be used to negate a decision but
that still doesn't mean that the court
would consider this type of ruling to be
without value You Know Chief Justice
Roberts has repeatedly said that the
best way to end discrimination is to
stop discriminating on the basis of race
and he still clearly maintains that so
there's some on the court that want the
clarity of removing this criteria from
uh from application processes let me get
brief thoughts on a couple of other
cases um one is considering section two
of the Voting Rights Act how
congressional districts are drawn this
is out of Alabama section two prohibits
voting practices or procedures that
discriminate on the basis of race some
advocacy groups said the way that
Alabama Drew its Congressional map last
time was discriminatory that there
should be two African-American heavy
districts not just one I wonder what the
implications might be here for future
elections and other states and drawing
Maps depending on this decision well
there's a couple of cases like Meryl
that you just referred to that could
have pronounced impacts one as you noted
is whether the court will continue to
narrow the Voting Rights Act in its
application to states there is also a
case called more where you have
Republicans arguing that courts should
have no role in their districting
decisions under the Constitution which
refers to legislatures as setting these
rules for elections the combination of
those cases could have a very big impact
a case that is probably my favorite of
these matinee cases is 303 creative
versus Atlantis and as someone who
writes a lot in the Free Speech area
this is in my view potentially the
greatest Free Speech case in in decades
and I it is hard to overstate the impact
of 303 creative see for years we've gone
through this question of whether states
can force people who do creative
products like photography Bakers web
designers as in 303 creative whether
they can require those people to produce
products Force same-sex
ceremonies or other types of events that
they have religious objections to
and this was an issue in the in the
masterpiece cake shop case that went to
the court previously the court took an
off-ramp and ultimately sort of ruled in
the favor of the baker in that case but
really left him dangling in the Wind
303 creative is everything Masterpiece
was not among other things it went to
the court raising both free speech and
religion clause challenges some of us
have written including myself that we
believe these are really free speech
cases not religious cases and it should
be resolved on Free Speech grounds well
that's why I was happy when the court
accepted only one question for 303
creative and that is free speech so it
could be now laying the groundwork for a
major decision that will address this
question of how far states can go in
requiring people to essentially speak
Professor Jonathan Turley thanks for
joining us
well thank you